hello folks and
welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics
right everybody else does
mathematics and irrational explanations
here we only do rational explanations
something you can visualize
we do it with objects we divide our
class
typically in three parts first part
we're going to deal with extinction
which is a branch of physics
physical objects disappear become
extinct okay
and then we're going to do a little bit
of physics which has to do
today with superposition
quantum superposition and then we're
going to move on to
the questions and comments that people
made since last time
okay so let's get on the road here uh we
start with a
little article okay that came out uh
someone pointed it out to me and so i
looked at a couple more comes from uh
newspaper magazine uh in uh
in the uk uh the guardian okay
and uh it's a little old it's about 10
years old but it really puts the
subject kind of like on the map
okay it says how neanderthals met
grizzly fate
devoured by humans we ate them up
that's how they became that's how they
became extinct
but that's one verse another version is
that first one there neanderthal live on
in the dna of humans some people say
that we
did not kill them what we did was
intermarry with them
and of course there's a famous or
ubiquitous uh
climate change okay everybody says that
we out competed them because they could
not compete
with the new climate that
befell the earth okay and there are
other versions
along those lines but essentially the um
the uh worldly wisdom out there
especially among paleontologists who
passed that on to
everybody else is that um
we had something to do with the
extinction of the neanderthals okay
and uh so all i can do is give you my
ten cents worth
on uh the neanderthal extinction i wrote
a book about it okay
how the neanderthals uh disappeared
and this is essentially my uh series of
arguments
against what is known as admixture in
other words
uh the fact that we did not interbreed
with them
it turns out i start by saying that we
never even met them
not for the purposes of competition
of wiping them out of intermarrying with
them
any of those in other words we had
nothing to do with the extinction of the
neanderthals which is
essentially the uh version of
paleontologists the official version
so let's go with that first one never
met okay let's see if we can find out
if we ever met them okay and it comes
from a
question uh an individual put out their
uh comment
and he says high-end paper claims that
the early presence of atomically
modern humans in mediterranean europe is
uh by forty five thousand to thirty
forty
three thousand uh years ago right
compared to
instead of thirty five thousand years
ago so there's a difference there of
uh anywhere from eight to ten thousand
years
and so the question is which is true did
the uh
did the early man atomically modern
humans crow magnanimo
uh did he under europe
35 000 years ago or 45 000 years ago
that's the issue because if humans
entered
uh europe 45 000 years ago
and as we will see in a second um
the neanderthals allegedly died around
40 000 years ago
they had 5 000 years to do their
intermarrying
the killing the climate change
competition that sort of thing you know
they can do any of those but if we never
met them
then all those theories go out the door
okay so that's this is the issue okay
the issue is
did we meet the neanderthals where are
we in europe 45
000 years ago or did we arrive 35 000
years ago about
five thousand years after the
neanderthals were gone
okay so that's the issue and uh
i can point here to another paper by
hayam
okay and he's uh he's a guy from oxford
okay and what he does is he typically um
measures the um
through through diverse means right he
checks
uh to see uh he dates things in other
he's got a dating machine over there and
he does
dating especially for uh for
neanderthals
and so he's considered an authority on
dating okay
dating meaning not going out with girls
but uh dating meaning he can date
uh fossils quite accurately he's
considered an expert uh
an authority on that issue okay so we
that's the best we've got so we gotta go
with whatever he he's telling us
and again a lot of the paleontologists
do not agree
with him it's important to understand
that but in a paper he wrote in 2014 the
timing of spatial
spatial temporal patterning of
neanderthal disappearings
uh he argues and that's more or less
what is accepted today
that the mustering technology meaning
that the
technology that the neanderthals handled
disappeared
about 40 000 years ago okay
now that's important because if that's
when the neanderthals disappeared you've
got eric trinkhaus which is another
so-called expert of paleontologist
paleontology and all these guys by the
way
uh subscribe to the interbreeding theory
okay so that's important to note
here uh tranquil says that uh the
first human that we found mandible
uh um you know there was uh anatomically
modern human cro-magnon okay
our forefathers or whatever you want to
call them uh
appeared for the first time thirty five
thousand years ago approximately that's
what uh trinkles
uh argues in his paper
and there were a couple more papers and
that's important to note i'm just going
to mention a couple here
uh and that's that um one is uh that
the neanderthals i'm sorry that yeah
they found an anatomically modern human
in bulgaria
a place called uh bacco kiro and there's
also
one in uh czechoslovakia a woman they
found
okay and again the big problem here is
when did these
uh samples
what's the date of these samples and
they go anywhere from 35 to 45 000 years
ago
again we've got this range this long
range
and the question is whether it's closer
to 45 or it's closer to 35
and what i want to point out here in
this map is that as you see on the
left-hand side there
you see the neanderthals pretty much are
thought to have disappeared
in the uh iberic peninsula in spain
that region there that's when the last
neanderthals are thought to have
uh lived and again they disappeared
anywhere between 40 to 44
000 years ago so you can see that
the first humans apparently are found
in the east and the last neanderthals
are found in the west
of europe the question is whether they
ever met
and all i can tell you is right now we
have no
solid evidence that they ever met in
other words
judging just by the samples that we've
uncovered
we have no evidence whatsoever that they
ever met
right now it's a very tight
a chronological schedule you could say
or timing as far as when
when these uh two met and whether they
met at all
okay my argument is that they never met
and the argument that i try to make let
me remove these here
and the try the argument i make is that
what kept anatomically modern humans
away from europe
where the neanderthals any any uh
uh human that would venture first into
the colder region
maybe they were following some herds of
animal and they were
drifting into neanderthal lands
i mean neanderthal empire we could call
call it
uh i think they were slaughtered the
neanderthals would immediately slaughter
them
and i think the neanderthals had the
upper hand
they had clans uh maybe their clans
were a little more numerous than uh the
number not the number of clans but
within the clan i think they're
they had more people than the migrating
humans
okay i'm not sure the humans could have
had these
herds of humans cattle uh going into
another land i think they were
relatively small groups smaller than the
neanderthals
as far as the numbers within each clan
and then got to remember one
thing clans always fought against clans
neanderthal against neanderthal humans
against humans
we were not friends no one was friends
in those days no one trusted anybody
any more than a lion trust another lion
we were all
enemies one clan was a the clan was the
country
that was your flag any other human
was a different country he was an enemy
he was a competitor he was someone who
came to kill you or steal
what you uh what you hunted or maybe
take your woman away or whatever
you know and the same with the
neanderthals so no one was a friend of
anyone
in those days okay so uh this issue of
uh whether they did interbreeding
already in my mind goes out the door
but if a small group if a band
a clan of humans ventured
into europe i think they would have been
slaughtered by the neanderthals and
that's why
we don't see humans in europe
before 35 maybe 40 000 years ago at the
most
whereas we see them in the far east
because we had no enemies over there
no no natural enemies such as the
neanderthals they're waiting
for us in europe i think uh you know we
were slaughtered
our forefathers were slaughtered okay
uh but i want to get back to the issue
of
dating because this is this is the
touchy issue okay
what they use for this is carbon 14
carbon 14 dating
and they say it's only good for
up to 50 000 years okay
but it's important to note that even
though it's actually
it's useful up to 50 000 years
in the past it's not very accurate at
all
and the closer you get to 50 000 years
the more disparities there are between
real and actual
uh real and theoretical okay
so what they're saying is that if if you
get to like 40
000 years ago maybe 35 000 years ago
maybe your your numbers are gonna be a
thousand two hundred years
off of whatever you you really you know
what really happened
your carbon 14 dating is going to be
maybe plus or minus a thousand a
thousand five hundred years
but when you get to like 50 000
then the difference is gonna grow all
the way to maybe eight
nine or ten thousand years that's how
different
these numbers are and i'm don't take my
word for it here i'm going to show you
what the so-called experts say here's
one he's a
famous fella from france his name is
jean-jacques hublin okay and he says the
following
he says radio carbon is the most precise
method
of directly dating human fossil remains
okay however at the limit of its
application
range around 45 to 40 000 calendar years
ago
which unfortunately corresponds to the
period of replacement of the last
neanderthals
it is highly sensitive to contamination
for a radiocarbon date of 25 000
years one percent contamination by
modern carbon will produce
an age that is a thousand six hundred
years too
young okay but for a radio carbon date
of 42
500 years the apparent age shifts 8
500 rounding off toward the present
they're going to be 8 500 they can be 8
500 years off okay
uh this length of time is in the higher
range
of estimates for possible overlap
between neanderthals and modern humans
at the scale of western eurasia so
there's uh
there's a little bit of a problem with
carbon dating and you have to take those
readings that these people give you as
truth
with a grain of salt you gotta you know
take it very
carefully you can't put your life uh bet
your life on those
uh readings and here's hayam himself
okay this is what he says within 30 000
years
98 of the already vanishing
vanishingly small quantities of carbon
14
in bone is gone and carbon 14 molecules
from surrounding soil start to seep
into the fossils collagen the part of
bone that contains the most
carbon suitable for dating softs up
contaminants like a sponge creating a
false record if just two percent
of the carbon atoms are contemporary
then a 44 000 year old bone will return
a carbon date of
33 000 years old heim calculates
so they could be 11 000 years off
okay what does that tell you about
carbon dating well it tells you that
it's
very inaccurate and that's all they've
got that's all they really have
for establishing the dates
of neanderthal disappearing
disappearance
and the arrival of humans allegedly from
africa
so if we could be 10 000 years off
all bets are off we have no idea of
anything
okay and yeah all we can do is just have
theories
and take the assumptions at face value
but don't put your life don't bet your
life for the assumptions
okay that's what i'm trying to say here
and
uh so let me go through uh
some of the reasons that i believe that
these neanderthals and humans did not
mate
which is the number one theory today
in addition to i don't think we killed
them if anything they would have killed
us
and uh i don't think we out competed
them i think that
we entered when the neanderthals were
essentially gone
as they were receding from the east to
the west and ended up
in spain we were advancing
that's about the same time and so we
probably never met neanderthal whenever
we did they would have slaughtered us
probably unless they were very few in
the end
then they had to run away but other than
that i think uh you know
we had nothing to do with their
extinction i think they were
the the neanderthal empire was imploding
so to speak okay
okay so uh let's put this back up here
and uh so the these are the arguments i
raise against uh admixture
i'm saying there's no empty dna no
mitochondrial dna
okay uh illustrated here and you'll find
that
uh people like sponta pablo and lots of
others you'll find all kinds of
uh reports out there that
uh will tell you that um you know the uh
we carry no uh mitochondrial dna now
mitochondrial dna is shown there
um comes from the mother okay it's
passed on from the mother to the
children
and so we had no neanderthal mothers
no proof of evidence today in our blood
in our
you know dna that we can we have ever
had a
negative mother so i don't know maybe
just neanderthal fathers
okay uh okay and then
then we have this nuclear dna okay
nuclear dna
yeah we inherited from both but it turns
out that uh you know these folks played
around with the numbers
and with some of their arguments and
some of their theories
when the max planck institute came up
with their 2010
seminal paper saying that we descend
from the neanderthals that there was
interbreeding because they found like
a little less than or around two percent
of commonality in our dna
well their uh their theory what they
were operating their tentative theory
was that europeans have more dna
and neanderthal dna than africans and
they were able to show that
however in the same report which you
know
was swept under the rug they also showed
and argued that
europeans should also have more
neanderthal dna than asians and american
indians
turns out that asians from papua new
guinea and american indians have
more neanderthal dna than europeans
now you explain that and of course they
have no explanation for that but they
swept that data under the rug
this is the issue the issue is that if
we're going to follow their logic and
say that yeah europeans should have more
neanderthal blood than africans and
again africans are said
many people think they had zero
neanderthal blood it's not the
dna from the neanderthal that's not true
it's very clear that we europeans have
more than africans but africans have
more than zero
okay that's an important point to
establish the other one is that if
we're going to operate with that
tentative theory we should also
operate under the other tentative theory
that we should europeans should have
more neanderthal dna than anyone on
planet earth
and that's not the case the papua new
guineas who knows how neanderthal ended
up there right
and the american indians have more dna
more commonality in dna where the
neanderthals and europeans
if you cannot explain that you don't
have a theory that's just as simple as
that
okay so uh yeah it's uh
just uh they were trying to push this
theory this inner breeding theory
because they have no other
solution to the neanderthal extinction
and so they
the the bit of data
that they selected was that europeans
have more than africans and they
let the other one die by pocket veto
they just put it away
so if you're going to do research look
for that
and you'll find your answer okay you'll
find clearly
that american indians have more
neanderthal dna than europeans the other
thing is they fudged around with uh
the data okay so this evidence there the
percentages
this is what they did if you look at
some of the papers that i looked at out
there
you'll find that the ones in yellow
there the 2010-2014 uh papers
they have tremendous differences in the
amount of
nuclear dna that humans
share with neanderthals the seminal
paper had anywhere from one to four
percent
and they said that it was closer to two
okay so they
they give this wider range which is
still small uh but
they they say it's around two uh the
the next one uh you see that's 1.5 to
2.1
but look at that last one they they
calculated that
all these other people mismeasured and
it's
we have really between three and seven
percent
this is what these folks came up with
and then when you look at
some of their arguments you see that
neanderthal dna uh
before 50 000 years ago they said
we had to have more than 10 percent one
one group says the other one says at
least that we had much more than two
percent
why because supposedly we lost some of
that over time
okay that's the the theory the theory is
that
uh 50 000 years ago we had anywhere
you know greater than ten percent and
over the years we lost some of that
until today we ended up with two percent
well it turns out that they found this
um uh
alleged uh human okay ustim
human supposedly dated to 45 000 years
ago which again
that's those numbers are not reliable
but they said this guy
uh when they did his um genome they
found that he had only two percent
in common with the neanderthals and so
you say hold it
uh the theory was that uh in the past we
had more than ten percent
uh and that we lost a lot of that over
time that's why we ended up today with
around two percent
it turns out that this uh uh ustim
human he already had two percent and he
lived allegedly around 45 000 years ago
so we got a problem because these people
are fudging around with the numbers just
to get their papers published
that's all it is there is nothing here
that you can
put your hand in the fire for absolutely
none of it
okay and it's all because they want to
push this inner breeding theory at all
costs
and against all odds okay uh then we
have the jewish nando's all
what i call they found um
they found um uh some skeletons or some
fossils in uh shenandoah and um
here i've got this uh place here
uh what's the other place
well there's there's uh i can't remember
the cave name in
israel and they found these uh
neanderthals
in the middle east okay iraq syria and
israel i call them the jewish
neanderthals because
that's where most of the papers come
from okay it turns out that
the people who do the studies on these
bones
several important people there say that
those neanderthals in the middle east
are a little bit different than the
neanderthals
in the west in france belgium germany
and spain
they're not the same and they looked at
the bones and they said look these guys
have many features that are not even
similar
so these are not neanderthals and i
doubt very much the neanderthals
ever ventured that far south
they were it's like a polar bear trying
to go south why would a polar bear go
south when
the polar bear is born in an arctic
environment that's the same thing that
happened to
neanderthals he came out of heidelberg
who came out of
homo erectus and homo erectus already
you know you have a site in
happinessburg in england
and the site is dated to 800 000 years
ago
and there was some two-legged creature a
humanoid of some kind
and the best you can come up with is
homo erectus
and from there you can imagine hydro
blur came around
and from there you can imagine that uh
neanderthal came around from
different branches so nanothon was born
in the cold he had no reason to go to
israel where it was
kind of hot hot climate okay and so i
don't think neanderthals ever
ventured that far and i don't think the
folks the
the skeletons they found in chanadar in
this
israel cave uh none of them uh
are neanderthal so you know uh there's
there have been no jewish neanderthals
as as i call them
uh race for this is species well you
know uh where uh
neanderthals and humans the same species
or were they just
uh were they different races or were
they different species
different species you cannot interbreed
in
interbreed successfully that's that's my
definition
and if you can well then you're
different you could be different races
that's it
and so the question is you know were
they different species or different
races which of the two races they can
interbreed
uh if they were different species all
bets are out
and um and i'm saying that they were
different species first because
uh humans supposedly my assumption is
that they
evolved in africa and migrated to europe
whereas
uh neanderthals were born in europe and
all they knew was cold and so
and they were separated maybe by 500 000
years from their
original you know their where the they
branched out
maybe 500 000 600 thousand years ago
maybe more because
you know if you go all the way to homo
erectus then you're talking about closer
to a million years ago
and so humans developed in a different
environment
than the neanderthals they had different
genes you know
i don't think they could have you know
made it
i'm not sure uh if a polar bear can
can mate with a bear somewhere south
burger far south i don't know if they
can make maybe they can but
again these are things that you got to
analyze uh
if a uh we would have to have like a
polar bear
i'm sorry we would have to have a bear
somewhere close to the equator
that lives there that uh evolved in
close to the equator and if that
animal could mate you know with with a
polar bear
uh we have the situation also for
example for elephants
could an elephant any elephant today
mate
with a mammoth and i think the answer is
no
mammoth essentially was or the mastodon
these were animals of the
arctic and you know you have the indian
elephant today
i don't think that animal if if we could
you know have
a um a mammoth today i don't think they
could paint
they were too far apart okay so
uh yeah i think they were different
species and so
inner breeding was out um half breeds we
haven't found any
and here you uh see what i'm talking
about we have no missing links
okay and this is a little thing that i
put out there you know
60 000 years ago all the way to 30 000
years ago do we find any missing links
going from
neanderthals to humans any half breeds
uh the answer is no we don't we don't
have this
okay and uh some people say that you
know
maybe we had some children out there and
they found a few
um fishy mandibles but uh those are very
questionable whether
some of these are neanderthal or whether
they are human
okay the the jury is still out and here
you have just one uh
expert supposedly tattersall ian tarasol
from
england and his claims of evidence of
transition
meaning you know uh again interbreeding
uh
between neanderthals and moderns based
on supposedly intermediate fossils
dating
from a short window of time around 40 to
30 000 years ago
have been refuted by the recognition
that the fossils
concerned are either typically
neanderthal or modern
and in one significant case had been
misstated
and you see here uh something to look
for if you're doing research out there
the mandible of a human contains a chin
okay and they found one 24 000 years ago
they made a lot of
uh fuss about it the lagarvello
child in portugal and he was dated to 24
000 years ago and he said
see we found a um a
neanderthal a half breed really a half
half neanderthal half
human and he lived 24 000 years ago
that's way after
the neanderthal disappeared 40 000 years
ago
and so here's evidence that we
but it turns out that the kid um has a
chin
and you can see the one on the right uh
they don't have chins those are
neanderthal mandibles
and you can see that the dimple that um
indentation there that going in there
that's human humans are the only ones
that have that
all other apes big apes whatever you
want to call them
humanoids hominids
uh all those don't have chin the chin
goes flat straight down
so that's what you have to look for okay
and so all i can tell you is that um
you know there's a big push to uh
consider uh to to discover
uh some half breeds and they haven't
found them and why because
at all costs they want to push the inner
breeding theory
they are saying that humans mated with
neanderthals because otherwise they have
no explanation for the disappearance of
neanderthals okay okay um
so here's a couple more uh close
okay and uh you know when we came into
uh art at the arctic weathers we we had
clothes
we had to have clothes because we
weren't used to that cold whereas the
neanderthals they never
wore clothes for sure they never wore
sandals or boots
you know these animals were were born
these gorillas were born
in that environment and so i think
neanderthal would probably
look more like the guy in the right than
the way they paint paint them today you
know if you look at
how they uh picture them today
you can see what happened the
neanderthal evolution that happened in
the 20th century
1909 this was the first neanderthal
drawn
and then you can see what happened over
the years 61 they became
lighter and more closed
and uh by the time we get to 2013 i had
to
censor some parts there so i don't get
shut down
and today you know they even dress them
up in clothes to just make sure that
when you look at them you think of a
human that's
with a you know many maybe a little
funny face he's got the
protruding eyebrows the the flat chin
and the big nose so so they put them
like that but they say look you know
they dress them up so that you can think
of them as a human
this is all propaganda that's all this
is okay
and uh so so you know you got to be
careful with how they're
trying to influence you through um
through all these pictures
and again if you look at the ribcages of
these guys you can see that the
neanderthal one was kind of
open okay it was a bigger rib cage
and the skulls obviously are different
so
to say that we made it with these
uh close to gorillas uh i don't think so
and again look at the chin there we had
a chandelier
i'm sure they look we looked a lot
different especially when we came with
clothes
uh that must have startled the poor
nando though they probably got scared
and they
attacked us and killed us they say what
is this creature with clothes on what is
that
why does he need clothes the weather's
warm
40 degrees below zero it's just fine
okay and this is me at the metman museum
with good ol
uh well there that's the neanderthal
museum here up here in germany
okay i went there to see
uh the neanderthals anyways
um then we have this a couple more
issues uh just
you know did we rape the women did they
nearly
rape our women is that how it happened
or did the women go voluntarily was it
was it a consensual
how did this happen okay and so
and then the other one is that uh you
know uh
people who who talk about in
interbreeding
they're not i don't even think they're
in the ballpark they're not they don't
have their feet
planted on the earth and the reason is
you know
a woman would not stray far away from
the cave or from her clan
she doesn't know what animal she might
find out there among others a
neanderthal
so she's not going to venture out all by
herself
either consensually or being raped i
don't think it ever happened because
a woman's not going to leave her clan
not so easily at least okay she's got to
be careful because she's out there
what's she going to do
hunt by herself no uh we are
social animals both the neanderthals and
us we were social animals
we worked in groups okay and so
you know you have to be like i say
within shouting distance
you know there's no 9-1-1 no no
telephone that you can
call your group and say oh i'm in
trouble sos no
none of that you're on your own and it's
not only nandos it could be any
animal that could pounce upon you the
men had to be there with their spears
ready to kill that animal if
it was like a you know a lion or
whatever
so i don't think the neanderthals had
any chance
at least to do rape was it consensual
did we just you know meet with them and
have a big party
pull out the beers and start having you
know dancing around singing and
exchange wives is that how it happened
no uh you're these people are out of
their minds completely out of their mind
they have no idea they should take a
course in anthropology a
beginner's course there's absolutely no
way
that two species first with mate
because the clans within these species
already
considered the other clan within the
species enemies
let alone some other creature that
looked different
they were venturing on their territory
under hunting grounds
you think that they're gonna share
they're gonna share the bounty
we've had cases where they say that both
neanderthals and humans as i started out
this
talk here uh butchered
in one case uh supposedly humans
butchered a neanderthal in another case
uh neanderthal butchered some other
neanderthal
you think when they're starving and
they're just
at beer subsistence level they're gonna
go out there and say oh let's have some
a party and have sex and and bring the
girls and
and swap partners these people are
totally out of their minds
so they're going with the evidence
because that's all they can think about
and they interpret the evidence such a
way that it fits their preconceived
notions which is integrating so yeah i
have uh
very little very little faith in these
people okay okay on to the questions in
extinction one file
says name one other mammal capable of
growing and raising food and has the
ability to produce high technology
isn't this what separates humans from
animals
uh well the way we do it in science we
do it a little differently what we do is
we
you know we define the word animal and
either man belongs to the world of
animals or he does not it's a black or
white issue
it is irrational to use words
inconsistently in science right
theorist is simply trying to sneak a
deep held belief into science when he
does that when he
defines something and then doesn't
follow his definition
strictly okay he doesn't use it
consistently
and then the question is is the cheetah
not an animal because it runs too fast
is the whale not an animal because it's
so big i mean the fact that we can think
we have this ability to think does that
much better than
other animals does that mean that we're
not an animal because we can think
even though all other animals have some
ability to think as well
we're just the we have we're the super
thinkers
well the cheetahs the super runner and
the whale the super big
super great uh does that mean that a
cheetah is not an animal
and then uh we have to look at what
makes us like animals pursuant to the
definition we simply have to apply the
definition consistently
any exception requires redefining the
word
animal so if you have an exception and
say look
we're not animals because no problem
just define the word animal
in in a way that you can incorporate
your
theory and it's got to be consistent
then you have to apply that same
definition over and over to
all animals okay you can't say well i'm
going to make an exception for the word
animal here and i'm going to say man's
not an animal
no no no problem you can do that but
right you have to define the word in
such a
animal in such a way that you can you're
allowed to do that
you can't just use the same word animal
and then say banan's not an animal
because
no no if he's not animal because
redefine the word animal
that's how simple it is okay same fella
says
uh he says have you looked into your
urban
uh environment self-sufficiency he's
talking about whether
you know um we're talking about
extinction here and so
once um as i say money disappears then
uh it's the end of the world we no one
produces food or distributes it and we
all
or the majority of us die of starvation
so this fellow talks about
self-sufficiency and he says
i've been eating uh chef's salads made
from dandelion leaf while hem
you uh leaf et cetera et cetera et
cetera he says he he's self-sufficient
okay i have
uh snares for catching rabbit et cetera
et cetera he says he can take care of
himself without
going out there and having to buy
at the supermarket okay okay what is the
problem well the problem is defense
that's the problem that's this issue you
have to address not
not whether you're self-sufficient
whether you can plant a a garden sure
anyone can plant the garden today
because you've got the protection of
9-1-1 the
courts the police uh the army you have
we take uh security for granted okay
the problem is defense will you trust
that man who's coming towards you with
this friendly hand
and a smile you know and uh with a gun
in his other hand
okay is that the guy you're gonna trust
that cowboy there saying hey
uh why don't we share in the bounty your
bounty with my starving family
yeah i'm sure you're gonna trust them
and in the jungle no
animal trusts okay and so yeah this
fellow
must have a problem because he probably
doesn't belong to the world of animals
if
if he doesn't follow the basic rules of
all animals which is you know you don't
trust in a jungle
no one trusts okay so
uh after the world collapses
we're back to the old days the
paleolithic
where nobody trusts anybody except that
we live in a
an asphalt jungle we have all these
buildings they're all empty
of food primarily there's no uh
wildebeest running uh through the
highways
so we have no food no one has given us
food because no one produced food
because we had nothing to give in
exchange for food because money is no
more
and so now we're stuck in the cities
lots most people will be stuck in the
cities
and what do we do well i think first
thing everybody does is first eat
whatever they have then
they start grabbing their guns some kind
of defense or
attack thingy
and go out to the country and see what
they can find and so here's this fella
and he's
he's gonna trust people he's gonna teach
him how to plant
yeah yeah they're gonna wait four months
that's assuming
you know they come i don't know in the
northern hemisphere in march
and you just plant it and you can teach
them how to plant
and you wait till september october for
harvest season
and you say see you waited four months
without eating
and now you can finally eat a little bit
of corn and whatever
yeah sure and that's again if if they
come in march
if they come at the end of harvest
season when all the
food is gone or where you stacked it up
all they're going to do is just
go through your whole garden
and good luck protecting them yeah
anyways uh for extinction of
101 before 102 i always say you got to
figure out
how the animals in the past died if you
can figure that out
then you can extrapolate that mechanism
to man
and figure out if man can
overcome that same mechanism that all
other animals in the past could not
does our intelligence does our
technology does our ability to
have foresight does any of that help
in any way whatsoever with the
cause of a mass extinction once you
figure that out well well then you can
apply it to humans okay
and again uh here's the homework
question i'll put it up
over and over why did the founder and
the seas disappear at the same time as
those on land
okay if you can figure that out well you
have a very
good clue as to uh
what happened to the animals in the past
and then
if you can extrapolate that to man you
have a very good clue
of why man himself is going to disappear
and very soon
okay let's move on to the subject of
today which is
what it's superposition what is
superposition i heard of superman
supergirl superboy uh superposition what
is that
let's find out well we covered the other
day we covered decoherence
okay and uh so this is what briefly what
the coherence was all about
particle at two places at once and they
always use this uh
slit experiment you shoot one ball and
the ball is at two places at once
at each of the two slits and uh
then they come together somehow and they
make the fringes
so how can this ball be at two places at
once it's not that ball
breaks in half or turns into two balls
no
it's the same ball at two places at once
if you can understand that okay and the
photon is simultaneously
both an extended wave and
a point corpuscle that's what the
coherence essentially comes down to
okay so that's the logic you can call it
if you can call it logic at all
okay okay um then we went on to
entanglement
and here's entanglement these are
properties that they found that they
proved
in quant in quantum mechanics okay and
what a quantum mechanic and what is
entanglement well particle here affects
one over there okay with now without
any physical mediator there's nothing in
between the two particles
and there you can see a little uh
picture of that
a little video there uh clockwise on the
left
counter clockwise on the right you
switch them around and now one
instantaneously changes the other
influences the other particle
even though they're not connected in any
physical way
and even though you know these particles
are millions
of uh miles away from each other
so how do you explain this what's the
explanation
they say it is so okay let's concede
let's concede i have no problem all can
see why
what causes that and that's where they
fail they cannot explain this especially
with particles
okay and uh so they talk about
instantaneous action at the distance
it's instantaneous you throw one the
other one twirls in one way then they
re-twirled it in the other direction and
the other one is measured to
be twirling in the other opposite
direction as well instantaneously
okay so they say okay so this is what
quantum proposes
again no explanation is just a
description
they say this is what we observe and
they leave it at that because they only
do
descriptions okay so those are
properties that
they supposedly proved discovered
observed
as they like to say uh in quantum
mechanics well
and here comes the third one and that's
a superposition
we're going to talk about today and what
do they say they say
the quantum in quantum physics and adam
can be
excited and not excited at the same time
it's excited and not excited at the same
time simultaneously
now does that make any sense to you okay
it's uh a bit scary that's what it is
because uh
these are phds okay they studied 10
years at a university
and they believe in this explanation
they say this is the physical
interpretation that we have today
that's that you know uh
the particle can be vibrating and not
vibrating at the same time
expanding and not expanding uh
you can go over and over just apply any
anything that you can think of
how can something be vibrating and not
vibrating at the same time
what sense does that make and of course
they don't make any sense of it
okay and that's the issue okay and so
here's the definition so that you don't
take my word for it uh
these are one is from one side the other
one's from the wikipedia
and these are the definitions they have
for superposition
superposition is the ability of a
quantum system to be in
multiple states at the same time until
it is measured then it collapses to one
or the other
okay and the concept is difficult to
understand
no kidding uh no it's not
i understood you perfectly it's
irrational that's what it is
don't tell me it's difficult to
understand tell me it's impossible
to uh comprehend it's impossible to
illustrate
to visualize the picture so this is
absolute nonsense you cannot say
that it has both of these properties at
the same time that it's uh
vibrating and not vibrating and then you
see the wikipedia there says quantum
superposition
is a fundamental principle of quantum
mechanics
okay great states that much like waves
in classical
physics any two or more quantum states
can be
superposed and the result will be
another valid quantum state
and conversely that every quantum state
can be represented as a sum
of two or more distinct states
this is their notion this is what
they're saying folks
let's get it right this uh this is the
picture of what they're
trying to say saying that the horse
is standing still and at the same time
it's running
that's what they're saying how can how
can you picture this
well i tried my best to picture it but
see uh even i cannot
understand what i put there how can the
horse be
running galloping and at the same time
be standing still
this is what these people are saying now
i want you to look at that does that
make any sense
whatsoever and no the answer is at least
to
my understanding uh rational folk
will never understand this there is no
explanation and these people admit it
they say
uh they don't understand it either where
does this all come from
well it comes from uh really you know if
you can if you want to trace it back
you'll find it here
you'll find it to these two gentlemen uh
beginning of the
20th century uh mr niels bohr
and ernst rutherford and they came up
with their planetary model of the atom
they do it all with little particles
okay they didn't have the three uh
quarks in the center then but that is
the model today
and it's a planetary model and nothing
has changed in a hundred years
people say well no it's not the same one
it is the same one
because this is the atom that they're
going to use for electricity to
to illustrate electricity it's the same
atom they're going to use for
ionization and the same atom that
they're going to use for what you're
seeing there which is the quantum jump
there's a electron falls to a lower
energy level
and it emits energy and when it rises it
absorbs energy
that's that arrow that you see coming
into that squiggly arrow
that's the so-called energy this is the
model that people use today to explain
those three phenomena
okay and again i always say you know why
does the electron fall to the center of
the atom which is one of the things that
these individuals try to explain
okay why doesn't it fly away
spontaneously
that's what you got to explain the blue
ball seems to always be
faithful to those rings and those rings
don't exist those are known as
energy levels which is a mathematical
concept we have no idea what those are i
mean are those
uh shells what are those i mean physical
shells
what are those things and they're not
not not according to quantum so when you
look at that
you say what are they talking what's the
physical interpretation
and you won't find one and don't take my
word for it here you i'm gonna give you
authority we're going to let the
horse the galloping horse and the static
horse
speak for themselves you're going to
hear from the horse's mouth this is boar
okay this is what he said about quantum
mechanics after
you know he gave it a lot of thought
during many years these are his comments
okay
so this is what you got to keep in mind
there is only an abstract quantum
physical description not explanation
description
it is wrong to think that the task of
physics is to find out how nature
is physics concerns what we can say
about nature if quantum mechanics hasn't
profoundly shocked you
you're an ignorant fool
you haven't understood it yet that's
what he's saying it's got to shock you
because no one can understand it
everything we call real is made of
things that cannot be regarded as
real this is what he's saying after many
years of studying quantum mechanics so
researching etc nothing exists until
it is measured so uh
you know that uh felons on the other
side of the planet
uh he doesn't exist because you haven't
measured it you don't see him you don't
touch him you're not measuring him so he
doesn't exist
that's what he's saying so you figure it
out is that a good definition of the
word exist
and yeah this is the way they use it
they have faulty definitions
they throw around the definitions of
ordinary speech
they bring them into science casually
and you say well yeah i know what he's
saying he's saying if you don't measure
it
then you can't touch or see it so
obviously it doesn't exist
well does the chinese man on the other
side of the planet exist
you haven't seen him you don't touch him
you don't measure him does he exist
and you might say well he doesn't exist
to me well that's too subjective you
know we need a little more uh
scientific definition of the word exists
something that we can apply
in every situation and that's what we
don't have from these folks
okay here's uh good old heisei eisenberg
this is what he said about quantum okay
and about
all this stuff all these properties that
they allegedly proved and discovered etc
it says the copenhagen interpretation
which was the bore
heisenberg uh version which was from
copenhagen uh denmark where uh niels
bohr was from he
created a school of thought okay and he
called the copenhagen interpretation of
quantum mechanics which is really the
one that's still strong today
okay has led physicists far away from
the simplistic
materialistic views that prevailed in
the natural sciences
of the 19th century they would prefer to
go back to the idea of what
an objective world so they're talking
so what is heisi saying he's saying that
quantum mechanics is subjective
there is no objective world out there
that's what he's telling you
okay in the experiments of the 50s and
60s
many new particles were discovered with
long and short lives
and no unambiguous answer could be given
any longer to the question about what
these particles consisted of
since this question no longer has a
rational
meaning okay
and that is no doubt the most important
experimental discovery of the last
50 years that
it has now meaning you can cannot
understand it
they have no explanation for it the
natural laws of quantum theory
no longer deal with the elementary
particles themselves
but with our knowledge of them okay
and really it's got to do a lot with
probability because quantum is a
probabilistic
theory they call it theory it's a
description probability is description
it's got nothing to do with explaining
so it's not a theory but they call it a
theory the theory part is the one that
they cannot explain which is
the mechanism that's that's a theory
that's what physics and science is about
and these people cannot explain it so
they turn mathematics
into science they turn mathematics into
theory
they took descriptions quantitative
descriptions and call those
theories and because they prove or
attempt to prove
mathematical equations they talk about
proving
theories okay so that's how this all
developed this is how it all
evolved okay and finally let's get a
foul who is more closer to our days he's
already dead
his uh richard feynman and he puts the
icing on a cake 50 years later than
you know when uh quantum came around in
the 20s
he said i think i could safely say that
nobody understands quantum mechanics
do not keep asking yourself if you can
possibly avoid it
but how can it be like that nobody knows
how it can be like that the more you see
how strange the nature behaves the
harder it is to make a
simple model that explains how even the
simplest phenomena
actually work explains he cannot explain
it
okay describe they can describe it they
can do probability they can do all that
stuff
they cannot explain the mechanism that's
what he's talking about
so he says so theoretical physics
mathematics has given up on that
they've given up on that they don't do
explanations anymore
they do explanations they give you a
mentally [ __ ] explanation they say
well yeah
and when you call their bluff they say
we know it's irrational
don't try to understand it and we don't
either and that's philosophy anyways
it's opinion what's important for them
is the math equations
and they call that science they call
that physics
that's how this whole thing developed
okay so what are my conclusions on
uh so this is how superposition came to
be okay so what are my conclusions on
superposition uh well together with
entanglement decoherence
uh here's a summary of all those really
the physical interpretation known as
superposition
arises because the mathematicians can't
peer into you know observe
uh what is going on in the invisible
invisible world
of atoms like i say so much for
observation as being part of the
scientific method i mean if observation
is a key uh feature of science
here these people are telling we cannot
observe
the invisible intangible stuff
that's mediating these transactions
these phenomena
then why do they say observe what are
they observing
what are they touching well they observe
touch actually they don't even observe
or touch those they
simulate them with computers okay
but because it's too fast too invisible
too untouchable
and so they simulate all this stuff with
computers and they put little balls in
there
particles they call them what are those
particles equations just the probability
of
something being there and they
illustrate that with a point because
they don't
pay any uh regards to um
you know structure architecture body
and so they just simulate those with
little balls
and so that you can see what's going on
because otherwise they wouldn't have
anything to what are they going to do
put an equation there and just move the
equation around
so now they put in a little ball and you
say okay i understand that this particle
collided against that one
but they're colliding our equations
probability of finding
an alleged particle in that region they
put the probability
it's an equation they simulate they
represent it within the equation that's
what they do in their computers
and so they calculate speeds energy
force
mass all that kind of charge you know
all that kind of stuff
which has nothing to do with physics we
want the physical interpretation we want
the explanation
and they don't have one and so the
question is what is observation for
what is observation of something you
cannot observe
by their own reckoning and then and then
they cannot touch it they cannot see it
and so why do they say
that science is about observing that
observation is
an important feature of science when
they cannot observe these things
and then superposition is yet another
irrational physical interpretation of
quantum mechanics together with the
other two the coherence
and entanglement okay
and it is not just that there is
unexplained
unjustified action at a distance
entanglement it is not that a particle
can be at two places at once
the coherence it is that a particle can
also be
vibrating and standing still
simultaneously
you know the horse is galloping and
standing still simultaneously
now that i think beats the other two
because
you know particle of two places at once
a particle being both
um i'm sorry
particle influencing another one from a
distance well those are already quite
irrational but this one where
you're looking at a little particle and
you're saying that that particle
is at the same time standing still and
vibrating
i don't know i think that beats the
other two but they're all very close
it's a
it's a very tight race there okay when
the mathematicians mathematicians i'm
sorry
use the word quantum to qualify
computers and dots and
all that's technology they're developing
right they insinuate that their theory
is correct and has been proved and
a lot of people take it like that
because they say well why would they
call it a quantum computer
if they have not proved quantum
mechanics obviously the computer
the existence of the computer the fact
that you have a computer you can use it
is proof evidence that the theory is
correct for otherwise you wouldn't have
the computer that's the reason
these people have and that's not
absolutely not true
one thing has nothing to do with the
other technology is one thing
the explanation is another thing what
these people
have is a description of
something they observed and they use the
classical part of that they use the part
that is touchable and seeable
and the invisible part you know they
describe it
they use it in in computing
like you would use a magnet to collect
iron filings
well yeah you can collect them that
doesn't mean you can understand or can
explain
how the magnet did it what the physical
mechanism
is and this is no different they're
saying you know the computer works
because we tried in the lab we found
this
effect and we applied the effect it
doesn't mean that they can
explain how the effect how mother nature
does that effect
that's the issue okay but they call them
quantum computer it confuses people
into thinking that these people
have the right theory because because
otherwise
the computer would not work that's their
tiny mental reasoning okay
and this hides the real situation they
can't explain the phenomenon
they can only in this case
superposition they can only describe it
with uh using particles which are
actually what equations
okay so that's in a nutshell not only
superposition but
entanglement and d coherence all in one
there you know they're all
irrational explanations but that's the
only explanation they have
and so uh this is where we're at today
they call it science
okay anyways let's get on with the
questions and the comments that people
made have a
few of these okay here's the first one
fellow says
electric universe he sends me to a site
okay and that's what he says that's in
that side i looked it up
electric universe advocates said that
the earth and other planets move
on a spiral and a planetary model we
learned in school was wrong
okay so he says there's a spiral okay
i'll show that in a second
in fact let me show that here real quick
okay
this is what he's saying okay let's put
it over here block myself out
okay uh you either have a forward solar
system or a helical solar system
and what we're seeing here is that
either the planets move
from forward to back as the ur as the
sun moves around the milky way
that means the sun squashes the
orbits in the direction of travel or you
have
the planets spiraling sideways with
respect to
90 degrees so to speak with respect to
the
direction of motion of the sun around
the uh
milky way okay so these are the two
proposals and what this fellow saying
that uh
the electric universe or at least some
people out there proposed the helical
solar system meaning that the planets
move
sideways with respect to the motion of
the
sun around the milky way and so he
continues
if the planets really move on a spiral
then the rope model to explain gravity
would be broken
i don't know where he got that nor how
he concluded that
and says i know there is nothing in the
rope model to allow this to happen
again maybe he doesn't know the rope
model
i don't know where he got this uh this
is it maybe his tiny brain comes up with
all this stuff
and the only way to have a spiral
trajectory is a charged particle moving
a
in a magnetic field well how does a
magnetic
a charged particle uh force anything to
go in a spiral
i mean unless the charged particle is is
connected to everything else
if the charged particle is a lone
particle how does it affect anything
how does it affect the particle next to
it if it's isolated from it
and then moving in a magnetic field
whatever a magnetic field is what is a
magnetic field
okay and so we went to the site to find
out what what the
the original uh fellow had to say
and it's what you find these are a
couple of statements i get from
uh his youtube video it says electric
universe is more accurate than
mainstream science
academic circles uh in other words uh
general relativity
and what do you mean more accurate what
does accuracy have to do with
anything okay so so this is the issue
these people
uh say things that have nothing to do
with the issue at hand
okay says uh the magnetic uh universe is
what we call the kingdom of god
oh my god god please they know not what
they do
uh kingdom of god that's what he calls
the magnetic universe a lot of people
you know talk about this nonsense about
you know god being the magnetic universe
the electric universe the world the
universe
okay yeah sure uh we have the word
universe for that we don't need god for
that
uh gravity is not two masses being
attracted to each other based on their
mass
aha like newton said okay then what is
it and he says
what is actually happening is that there
is a shaft
like the eye of a storm okay shaft
either the eye of the storm is not a
physical object but okay let's let's see
we can bear with this guy
in a tornado there is a shaft of
stillness that runs through the middle
of these vortices
vortices what is a vortex vortix
vortex vortices vortex is a concept
what is vorticine vortice or vordex
is a is a verb it's what a tornado does
it's
vortices it ruins trolls around it
spirals
that's what vortex means in this context
and so you got to tell me what is
vorticine you know what is moving around
what is spiraling
that's what you got to identify and so
you know
listening to this value is is worthless
it's a worth
um waste of your time okay
i wouldn't spend two two seconds on his
stuff because
it's just uh nonsense he's got no
explanation for
why plants would spiral around on the
other hand the rope model does because
every planet in the solar system is tied
to the earth through gazillions of ropes
now we have a physical
mechanism that's why i don't understand
why this guy doesn't understand he says
how is it that
you can explain that uh you know the
spiraling with ropes well if every
planet is attached to the sun
you know the sun twirls them around and
now if the sun moves forward
as the planets are rolling around you
know then yes you could
create this spiral pattern as the uh for
each planet as the or the sun moves
around the milky way
so no problem the road model handles it
fine either way
it handles the forward and the spire and
the spiraling brother they can handle
both
uh which way the sun is really moving
well you know that's
i don't really know it's up to other
people to determine we can handle both
cases the issue here is why do the
planets remain
uh faithful to the sun just like why
does the electron remain faithful
to the the proton or to the nucleus
same same issue you have to explain that
if you don't have a
mechanism a media you're a physical
mediator that binds one with the other
you have no theory you can't even start
your presentation because we're not done
with your assumptions
we need to find out what physical entity
connects them
okay otherwise you're putting spirits in
there you're putting
you're doing black magic you're doing it
with
non-objects with concepts with
mathematical concepts i don't know
abstractions okay another foul says
get this thing up here it says when the
spin changes on both
ends of these so-called ropes they would
untwist and twist
into the other direction so he's saying
uh you know
it's twirling in one direction and then
i turn mine in the opposite direction
now twirls in the other
one way it was clockwise the other one
is counterclockwise
well he says how does the signal go
from beginning to end faster than light
if that's instantaneous
and against what we i covered a minute
ago about this
polarization essentially that's what it
comes down to
the entanglement they say how can you
know
uh the atom over here spin in the same
direction or you know
from one direction it's clockwise from
the other it's counterclockwise and now
you turn this atom around the other one
in the opposite direction now they're
twirling in the opposite direction
well for light i can tell you for light
it never happens okay so instantaneous
is an irrational term that's the first
thing we have to get rid of
there is no such thing as instantaneous
motion
instantaneous is a picture motion is a
movie
never should the word instantaneous be
used with the word motion
and that's when it's always used they
say that something happened
ed verb instantaneously no such monster
in science no such monster in physics
okay now an electromagnetic robe always
spins either clockwise or
counterclockwise from a given
perspective
an electromagnetic rope does not change
the direction
it's spinning from clockwise to
counterclockwise or vice versa
therefore there is no signal sent faster
than light or instantaneously from one
atom to another
which um electromagnetic rope are we
measuring anyways
i mean can we identify an individual
electromagnetic rope
and let's put that question to the
photon how do the mathematicians
mathematicians i'm sorry know that
they're measuring
one photon more importantly how do you
know
okay how can you prove how can you
verify where's the evidence
that a photon is now spinning clockwise
rather than counterclockwise
can you show i mean a photon is point
particle that's what they say
and uh some say it's a wave and so the
question is
um how do you know that single photon
is spinning clockwise or
counterclockwise where did you get this
okay so uh yeah
the issue is uh and here we can show
this
let me show this give me a second here
this is aspects and then aspects
experiment i showed the other day
and you can see that the sensors those
cubics the boxes there uh
they're static and the way they do this
is through polarization essentially okay
linear
polarization what they do is they turn
maybe a quarter wave plate as it's known
or you know you've seen uh polarization
they have
the two vertical and then they move one
horizontal
and the beam is extinguished and that's
what they do here they apply that
notion and the question is whether we're
measuring
one photon whether we're measuring or
detecting or
sensing a single photon
a single wave uh transverse wave
how do they know they're measuring one
wave one
photon maybe they're looking at
gazillions of photons
okay how do they know they're handling
one atom
okay how do they know this when they
don't know what an atom looks like they
do not have
they do not have a um
you know a way of looking even with a
scanning electron microscope
you cannot see one atom especially one
hydrogen atom
what you would see if anything a complex
atom
from afar okay and
how do you know from that what's going
on how do you know which of the atoms
uh in other words hydrogen components
of that atom okay because if uranus
uranium has 92 hydrogen atoms
in it and it's got all these levels
uh s orbitals p
orbitals d orbitals and so on down line
if it's got all these orbitals how do
you know from which orbital
that signal came from the light
okay so what they do is uh they use
what i used in in the business which is
very common which is known as an
ellipsometer
the isometer looks more or less like
that and it's used to measure thin
films okay and it's got a polarizer and
an analyzer
sometimes got these quarter quarter wave
plates as they're called
and you can rotate this slightly and you
can change
uh the incoming signal to the detector
okay and so what you have is a
cross-section
of light and again the question is how
do you know you're measuring just
one photon how do you know you're
measuring just
one transverse wave just one transfer
wave of one
uh beam of light you could say how do
you know you're not measuring
many in fact you are because you know
you got gazillions of uh
waves going through there okay that's
the issue and so
they have no way of isolating one uh
one photon or one electron or one atom
they have no way they don't even know
what an and what a
electron looks like and they use a
point particle but then they say you
know like you have this
phelotanomora he said he handled one
electron at a time
i'll please draw a picture of it
tatamora that way i know
that you handled one electron at a time
what did it look like how do you know
you handled one electron at a time
and they don't they don't because they
don't know what an electron looks like
and in fact they simulate it as a point
particle they define it as a point
particle
and then they draw uh more than a point
particle they draw something that's got
size something's got
diameter radius you know
dimensions so yeah there's contradiction
they have to start with their atom they
got to show me their atom especially the
hydrogen atom
which is the simplest atom if you can't
show me your hydrogen atom
you can't tell me how that electron
doesn't fall to the center or fly away
spontaneously
you don't have an atom to start out with
you cannot talk about what's going on
physical interpretations mechanism
inside an atom is shooting one
electron ball or one photon ball
if you don't know what a photon or an
electron looks like you don't even know
what an atom looks like
okay so the physical interpretations are
all
suspect okay
another fella he says uh [ __ ] experiment
i tried
with a needle but i got only his single
straight shadow on the wall
i'm dumb or what well i don't know there
you see my experiment i've got that in a
video you can look it up
uh and i pointed a laser to a little
uh in fact i've got it here this is my
uh
needle on a cork okay little rubber cork
and you can see the the fringes on the
wall far away
okay maybe you don't have the right
distance i don't know i don't know what
you're doing wrong but this is a very
simple experiment to do
i'm doing it uh my billion dollar
experiment
i did it just off the cuff you know i
went to my
son's house and uh pointed the laser at
the
at the needle and i saw the fringes on
the wall there you see the fringes
very crude experiment but you can see
the fringes okay so there should be no
reason for you not to see
what i'm seeing there so i don't know
what you're doing wrong okay
uh you got to try to figure out okay
what you're doing wrong
okay um
another issue uh phil says
he says what do you think of the
expanding earth theory
okay let's find out uh what is he
talking about well he's talking about
the earth
becoming bigger over time and that would
explain why the continents
have separated in the way they look
today specifically they always point to
south america coming out of
africa okay that's the one that that
drives home the point for everybody okay
and uh
so here it is the expansion these are my
issues my questions to
whoever comes up with this theory i like
the theory i mean
i like it as for stimulating the mind
uh do i accept it as an assumption do i
follow this theory no i don't absolutely
not and that's because i've got these
questions the first one is
what is the expansion mechanism and then
by how much in other words uh did the
earth really expand so much that it
broke
off the the continent is so far away
from each other
is that's what these people are saying
and primarily i'm concerned again
with the um with a mechanism by what
mechanism
did the earth expand and here's uh the
people who came up with this theory
uh first guy was roberto montevani
and he was a 19 to 20
early 20th century fellow okay and he
was a geologist
he wrote a paper this is the oldest one
that i can find from 1924
allegedly he already had the idea all
the way to 1889. i couldn't find that i
could not
verify that exactly
i didn't have too much time to research
all his stuff but
this is uh his earliest paper as far as
i'm concerned for now
and um and he he came up with this idea
and then this was taken up by many other
people
and one of the fellows who took up uh
this idea was samuel carey
and he was an australian and what this
fellow said
he says he assumes that the mass of the
earth has been constant
he says i don't think so okay the
mainstream assumes that he says that
that's not true and then he says i think
that all matter in the universe grows at
a rate
depending on some power of pressure and
time
my god uh why am i worried about this
fella well he's
already dead now but see it turns out
that
he doesn't love he it takes one hour to
give you a description
just a bunch of descriptions
mathematical like
he talks about you know how this this uh
came out of that
because it looks more or less the same
he measures all this stuff great
he does all these descriptions i grant
them i don't even challenge them
what is the mechanism and what he says
is
mass grows that's it
one sentence that's all he spent in his
old
an entire dissertation on what caused
the expansion of the earth
and i have a little trouble with that
especially when they say mass
grows math expands math augments
you know this is nonsense that's not a
physical interpretation
give me a cause a mechanism
of why the earth expands what's pushing
the earth outwards
to the point where you know all these uh
uh
continents separate okay i don't have a
problem with the
with the description saying the the uh
continental drifts uh are caused by the
expansion of the earth okay conceive
i'm not even gonna challenge it i'm not
even gonna worry about that
what is the mechanism you don't have a
mechanism you don't have a theory
all you have is a description you're not
doing science okay so
i call this baloney stuff okay
it's baloney only until they have a
mechanism when someone comes up with a
mechanism that you can sink your teeth
into
then we have a theory then we have
something to deal with in physics then
we can challenge it or not challenge it
or come up with something better
better mousetrap as i say okay until
then
this just charlatanery that's all it is
charlatans
that's all they are okay they have these
theories these uh
ideas and they just shoot them out
without any any sustenance
uh without any backing without any
support okay
not physical support physics physical
interpretations mechanisms
causes that's what physics is about okay
another fellow says
uh says do you think your emotions and
thoughts are physical
mechanisms yet we can cause effect
and affect plants and water with them
okay what makes you think it has to be a
physical mechanism
that drives the universe okay so he says
that with his mind you know
concentrate very deeply bill you know
and he can move things around he can
influence
the water maybe get it to boil i don't
know or
uh get plants to grow or whatever i
don't know
okay we'll concede i don't even
challenge that
so far we have a description what i need
is the mechanism i need a description
and that's where all these religious
folks that's where they come up short
because otherwise he's using black magic
if he doesn't explain his music mac
magic and
uh pen to the floor you know uh
my experiment you need to tell me uh
that what the mechanism is there is no
physical mechanism
nothing comes in contact with the skin
of the pen
it always falls to the floor it doesn't
fall to the ceiling
uh you would think something's pulling
it to the center of the earth
everything falls to the floor uh and
nothing falls to the ceiling nothing
falls through the sky
and you can test this for yourself just
take any rock anywhere
at random you can choose your own rocket
you want to use a ball use a ball
and just go outside and let go of it
you'll see it doesn't go to the sky
never goes to the sky why why does it
fall to the earth
and there's only two possibilities only
two
something is physically pushing the ball
down coming in contact with the skin
of the ball or something is pulling me
on it something is coming in contact
with the skin of the ball from above
or from below anyone who says
otherwise is using black magic you can't
say
nothing came in contact with the skin of
the ball which is what this law is
saying i mean
look what he's saying he's saying uh
what makes you think it has to be a
physical mechanism that drives the
universe
so uh what does he propose uh
so i asked by what mechanism do you
propose emotions and thought
affect plants and water from from a
distance
i mean uh are you saying it's black
magic the witch there you know
if you say they do that's a description
what we want is a how a cause a
mechanism that's an explanation
physics deals with explanations of
mechanism not descriptions
anybody can describe and say oh i pulled
uh i picked up a bunch of um
iron filings with my magnet that's a
description
so far you haven't explained anything we
need to know how you did it
how the magnet did it by what mechanism
and hopefully something was in contact
with both the magnet
and the iron filings for the iron
findings to come towards
the magnet for otherwise you're using
black magic you're saying it was done by
spirits by god or who knows what
okay you don't have an explanation and
so until you have an explanation you
just
show that you're a religious fanatic you
haven't
explained anything you're just saying
god or it is
it is so yeah so okay
and final issue here uh foul says
that i believe that an object is that
which has shape
well we don't believe in science we
don't believe we define so we define
object as that which has shape okay
that's a definition
we follow the definition and we use it
consistently rationally
scientifically and it's the only
universal property of objects uh do you
know any
object that does not have shape
if you do please uh mention it next time
okay which
object that you know doesn't have shape
okay and
typically people have this c-touch
notion
they say an object is really that which
you can see or touch
well that's the case you know is the
table that you can't see the one that
klingon has on the other side of the
universe
is a table a physical object
is it an object if it ain't then you got
to define
then your definition is wrong because
you say see touch
so either you can see or touch it
or or it's not an object and here you
have a table
he can see and touch it you can't so
it's not a table for you
that's quite subjective you know
hopefully we have
a an objective definition one we can use
consistently
rationally scientifically
and with that i'll see you next time
i'll see you uh what is it on wednesday